IN MY NEW HOME WITH
MY NEW FAMILY.
OH, I--EXCUSE ME.
CAN YOU PUT ON A PAIR OF PANTS
FOR TONIGHT?
PUT ON A PAIR OF PANTS?
HE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND.
- NOPE.
- HOW COULD I BE MORE CLEAR?
MY PRESENCE HAS ALWAYS BEEN
A LIVELY ADDITION
TO ANY SOCIAL GATHERING,
BUT BEING
THE LIFE OF THE PARTY
WAS DIFFERENT.
I'D HAVE TO BE
THE FUNNEST PERSON IN THE ROOM,
AND I'D NEED SOME HELP FROM
MY OFFICE STAFF.
IF AT ANY TIME TONIGHT
YOU SEE ME FLOUNDERING--
LIKE I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
OR WHAT TO SAY, OKAY?--
I NEED YOU TO VERY DISCREETLY
READ ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
ON THESE CARDS.
YOU WILL BE PROMPTING ME TO
TELL SOME OF MY BEST ANECDOTES.
- MR. MACNEIL,
YOU GOT A PACKAGE.
- OH, THIS HAS GOT TO BE
MY NOVELTY ITEMS.
- OH.
- YES, YES! [laughs]
THIS IS JUST A BOX FULL OF FUN.
[laughs]
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
"THE BALD MEN'S COMB."
- BUT THERE'S NO--
OH, MY GOD, THAT'S SO FUNNY.
- YEAH.
THERE'S NO COMB IN THERE.
- HEY.
both: HELLO.
- OUT FIRST GUESTS!
- HEY.
- [laughs] OH, MY GOODNESS.
EXCUSE ME, EXCUSE ME, EXCUSE ME.
IGOR, I GOT IT, I GOT IT,
I GOT IT.
LET ME WELCOME OUR FIRST GUESTS.
WELCOME!
HEY, I HOPE YOU'RE READY
TO GET YOUR PARTY ON!
[laughs]
OH.
UH--[clears throat].
SO...
YOU KNOW, I MEAN, IT'S
A TYPICAL PARTY IN MOST WAYS,
UH, THAT WE HAVE PLANNED.
- HAS ANYONE HERE EVER LEARNED
TO SMOKE THEIR OWN SALMON?
- I'M FINE.
THANK YOU.
HOW ARE YOU?
AS MORE PEOPLE ARRIVED,
I DID MY BEST TO MAKE MEANINGFUL
CONNECTIONS WITH EVERYONE.
REMEMBER, WE TALKED ABOUT
THE ARMY,
AND HOW YOU WERE NEVER IN IT,
BUT ENJOY THE JACKET.
HOW ARE YOU?
ARE YOU A COUPLE? [laughs]
ALL RIGHT, I CAN SENSE THAT
YOU'RE NOT
AND I MADE IT AWKWARD.
SHOULD WE SHAKE HANDS?
I'M DOING FINE.
ANY ENTERTAINER WILL TELL YOU,
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO BE
ALL THINGS TO ALL PEOPLE.
BUT THAT'S WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
THE LIFE OF THE PARTY,
AND I WAS DETERMINED TO SUCCEED.
MY FRIEND!
I HAVE SOMETHING FOR YOU.
[laughs]
LOOK AT THE LABEL.
IT'S A BALD MAN'S COMB,
AND THE BOX IS EMPTY.
[claps]
[laughs]
SEAN, RIGHT?
- NO.
- NO?
WHO WANTS SOME MILK?
[laughs]
OH, LOOK AT THIS!
MILK COMES RIGHT OUT OF
THE BOOB.
- WHY WOULD I WANT MILK
IN MY BEER?
- WHY WOULD YOU WANT MILK
IN YOUR BEER?
YEAH, WELL, I DON'T KNOW,
BUT IT'S FUNNY!
[laughs]
AS THE EVENING PROGRESSED,
I ATTRACTED PLENTY OF ATTENTION
TO MYSELF.
BUT I ALSO ATTRACTED
COMPETITORS,
AND THERE CAN ONLY BE ONE
LIFE OF THE PARTY.
HEY, WHOA, LOOK AT THIS GUY.
OH, FANTASTIC.
OH, MY GOSH.
OH, THAT'S--OH, SHOOT.
NO ONE COULD BE MORE FUN
THAN ME.
- WHOO-HOO!
- AH!
- CAN I PLEASE TALK TO YOU GUYS?
HEY, GUYS.
- HEY.
- WHAT YOU WERE JUST DOING
IN THERE
WAS BEING THE LIFE OF THE PARTY.
I'M TRYING TO BE
THE LIFE OF THE PARTY.
JUST DON'T SAY ANYTHING ELSE FOR
THE REST OF THE NIGHT.
AND HE HAS TO GO.
GET--GET HIM OUT OF--
GET HIM OUT.
GET HIM OUT OF HERE, GO.
- OKAY.